hey sweet what Hulk Hogan against the
Sarge
who's gonna win its art without Shootist
agad what's that battle fielders so an
article by Eurogamer last week
highlighted how dice was a little
perplexed about what made the
battlefield bad company series so great
we took that as a challenge so here are
the top ten reasons why we think bad
company specifically Bad Company 2 was
the best battlefield ever made I do say
this acknowledging that PC players would
definitely say battlefield 2 was the
best and if we were just talking PC I
would agree with you number 1 map design
virtually every map in Bad Company 2
took you on a journey with completely
different topographical sections
particularly in rush mode the maps
meandered through desert thick jungle
across water through villages and up and
down hills most maps felt like several
different maps put together and that
kept the action fresh even the open
conquest design maps such as atacama
desert told the story of huge cargo
ships run aground take Golmud railway in
battlefield 4 for example what's the
story there
there's a field with a confused
locomotive in it you might sit together
on it when are we gonna get there coupla
minutes
about there oh okay rpj yeah aside
number two personality plus did you ever
just stop and listen to the [ __ ] that
comes out of Hagrid's mouth
well you should I think you're probably
allergic to love you're an angry man on
top of characters actually having
character and bad company the
single-player campaign also had this
great Indiana Jones lost relic thing
going for it
multiplayer also had a lot of
personality in its own way sitting
inside tanks he'd be looking at the
world through a green filter running
down the battlefield there'd be thick
smoke from blasts and tracer rounds
flying by your head bad company wasn't
wrapped up in being this serious war
drama and it worked really well
number three meaningful destruction in
Bad Company 2 you rarely had to guess
what was and was not destructible
because pretty much everything was how
many times have you run across a wall in
battlefield three or four and had no
clue if you could destroy it or not in
bad company 2 you had amazing building
to building fights rush crates in many
cases were on the second storey of
buildings that can be completely razed
which forced the defending team to
occasionally go on the offensive and
again that changed the pace of the game
or in another example thick forests
which never seem to have reappeared in
battlefield could be completely leveled
to make no man's land or left there to
hide troop movements destruction wasn't
just optional it was critical in
Battlefield Bad Company 2 number 4 DLC
that changed the game bad company to
Vietnam wasn't just DLC it was almost a
new game it had an entirely different
look and feel use new weapons and
remember the first time you came out of
the jungle on Hill 137 and just stopped
and stared at that napalm blasted
hillside damn you want to know why
people think battlefield hardline is DLC
blame Vietnam also maps in Bad Company 2
were designed for specific game modes
and then later repurposed free of charge
for others
did I say free Maps because there was
that too number 5 getting into another
round was fast when a round ended you
could just play another round almost
instantly and you didn't have to go to a
server browser to customize your loadout
I mean stare
at the end of round stat screen and
checking email is great and all but
playing another round is a hell of a lot
better also you didn't have to waste
time at the start of rounds configuring
your keyboard yes yes recently there was
test island but how long does it take
you to load that map
oh isn't this [ __ ] local
number six steam you could and can still
buy bad company to on steam steam is
more than a place we go to buy games
it's a thing that we love origin is just
a thing that couldn't succeed at
plagiarizing the thing we prefer to vote
with our dollars and steams where it's
at number seven
co-op bad company to had onslaught mode
on console did not make it to PC to be
fair battlefield 3 did have a co-op
campaign that was quite good when you
weren't getting booted from the
helicopter and fire from the sky but
onslaught mode was co-op on the actual
multiplayer maps it helped new players
learn those maps without having to take
a gustav rocket to the face from a
veteran player number eight the
single-player campaign didn't maniacally
try and control your every action
remember tactical freedom the thing you
had before battlefield 3 forced you to
knife a man in an upright position in a
non stealthy manner moving in an exact
speed or death now field 4 brought back
some of that but not like bad company
which had some levels so massive you can
free roam them at will
number 9 no premium if you're gonna sell
a discounted map pack then sell a
discounted map pack charging $120 for
battlefield then implementing a slow
unlock tree with bizarre free-to-play
ask experienced boosters with additional
paid battle pack content and paid
unlocks creates a lot of mistrust with
your players charge players reasonable
prices and give them fun that's it and
number 10 fewer weapons were more fun
bear with me now the sniper rifles in
Bad Company 2 were well balanced and
didn't throw footballs the m60 was a
little overpowered but that's why we
loved it
sniper scopes didn't harness the power
of the Sun to give away their position
and remember the mortar strike yeah that
thing killed campers and kept matches
moving the weapons in Bad Company 2 were
fewer but just more meaningful in the
way that they were diverse the game also
had impeccable hit detection and no
death shields so those are our top 10
reasons why we think Bad Company 2 was
the best battlefield dice ever made what
are your thoughts on the matter
have you gotten into the battlefield
hardline beta will you fight for
Battlefield 2 PC players how would you
suggest dice makes a sequel the Bad
Company if they ever agree to do such a
thing let us know in the comments below
and we
we'll see you out on the battlefield hey
I think we got Sarge on the ropes Hey
UFC cage fat okay you got your Hulk
Hogan he's a big man you put him in with
Liddell you know Chuck Liddell who's
gonna win chuckle it out do you think so
oh he was the best of the best but that
Christmas [ __ ] [ __ ] okay Jeff iton is in
charge you ever seen the cage place
prizes real every cage fighting is real
oh yeah man WWF real problem ws yeah
it's real something